Democratic Party leaders are promising
to improve the democratic process in the
wake of the uproar over the use of
super-delegates and recent presidential
primaries tonight correspondent Allison
barber looks at what the party is
considering and whether it would make
any real difference in the world of the
super-delegates super-delegates have
been used in the Democratic primary for
years to our party elected officials
sort of the uber activists to be given
voting rights at the convention
officials say super-delegates have never
overturned the will of the other
delegates but in 2008 and then again in
2016 they became a big issue within the
Democratic Party and to some proof of a
rigged system over 400 of these
super-delegates in the race party
officials disagree with that but
acknowledged that perception matters we
fell short in many ways in 2016 we fell
short in terms of making sure that
everybody felt that the candidate they
were supporting not a fair shake party
leaders created a unity reform
commission that made recommendations to
the parties rules and bylaws committee
as long as there is the perception of an
unfair process then you have an unfair
process any steps that the DNC takes to
turn that around are good steps this
month DNC members voted to accept the
committee's findings only those
unpledged delegates that have been
carved out than once I told you about
would have a vote on the first ballot so
we reduce the weight but some of the
committees members selected by senator
Bernie Sanders are less optimistic in an
email to supporters of the group our
revolution rights the DNC rules and
bylaws committee watered down our
agreed-upon much-needed reforms that
would open our party to independent
voters and level the playing field for
progressive candidates it looks like
it's up to us to push this change
forward this isn't a done deal just yet
the committee has until June to finish
its work DNC men
we'll look at everything again and vote
again during their summer meeting Brett
will follow it Ellison thank you